Marseille de crimes un assassin même
commanditaire le docteur Gall inculpé de
complicité
d'assassinat la tempête a fait des
ravages en Europe bilan provisoire 94
morts ou disparus bralm demain mais
attention
dimanche
cocas siabakou le CAL me semble revenu à
Moscou un leader azérie a été
arrêté bande dessinée max cabane à
l'honneur angoulem vient de lui décerner
son Grand Prix et nous le retrouverons
en direct bonsoir bonsoir Jacques de
rogis merci d'avoir répondu à notre
invitation vous êtes journaliste à
l'événement du jeudi vous êtes écrivain
et vous êtes avec Jean-Marie ponte
l'auteur d'un livre remarqué sur
Marseille une ville qui n'a aucun secret
pour vous alors vous allez nous donner
tout à l'heure de précieuses indications
sur ce feuilleton macabre qui
ensanglante et qui effrait le corps
médical mais aussi le corps municipal le
docteur Galot dont on a parlé hier
serait en effet le commanditaire deux
meurtres celui du docteur Péchard son
ex-collègue au conseil municipal et
celui de Léon smoth un directeur d'une
policlinique assassiné lui en mai 88 les
précisions de Jean-Marc
pit d'un médecin à l'autre l'enquête sur
l'assassinat du docteur Péchard à
Marseille s'est emballée aujourd'hui
Roger Memoli a avoué en même temps que
le meurtre de Jean-Jacques Péchard celui
de Léon smoth Léon smoth était directeur
de l'explyclinique Marseille Nord le 188
mai 88 il était abattu au volant de sa
voiture alors qu'il sortait de cet
établissement le commanditaire de cet
assassinat serait toujours selon mmoli
l'ancien directeur administratif de la
clinique Marc galeazi il a été placé en
garde- à vue cet après-midi et aurait
avoué ces deux affaires sont désormais
liées le parquet vient de requérir une
double inculpation pour Memoli qui a
avoué les deux meurtres mais aussi pour
Armand Galot et également médecin pour
complicité d'assassinat dans les deux
cas l'instruction de ces deux dossiers
étant dèlors mené de front on devrait
s'orienter vers la piste de la guerre
des cliniques le département des Bouches
du rô est frappé de l'interdiction de
créer de nouveaux lits dans
l'hospitalisation privée résultat les
cliniques de la ville se livrent à une
véritable bataille pour racheter les
droits d'exploitation cette bataille a
peut-être débordé des limites légales et
c'est le mot clé comme dit Jean-Marc pit
Guard des clinique c'est la toile de
fond de toute cette affaire 50 d'entre
elles ont changé de main en quelques
années à pour quelle raison les réponses
de Christian pechi de
Marseille se regrouper ou mourir pour
l'ensemble des cliniques française le
choix est simple puisque'aucune création
n'est possible selon la loi Barzac une
loi qui fige la carte du nombre de lit
dans notre région à 7000 il faut donc
racheter des lits coûte que coûte pour
survivre le nombre de lits est en
proportionné aux possibilités de choix
des spécialités médical et surtout
permettant d'investir dans du matériel
de
pointe une soif de mouvement qui
intéressé plus de 300 établissements
dans notre région des changements qui
n'ont pas fait que des heureux attisant
des haines voire certaines ranqueurs il
faut cependant se garder d'aller trop
vite et de conclure que toutes les
transactions marseillaises en matière de
clinique sont entachées de sang reste
que certaines opération financière
pourrait être à l'origine des règlements
de compte de ces derniers jours de
l'argent à blanchir pourrait expliquer
cette soif de lit quelle meilleure
couverture alors qu'une clinique à moins
à moins que tout simplement les
relations humaines et passionnelles
soient les seuls est unique mobile des
crimes alors clinique ou relation
passionnelle Jacques on certainement les
deux parce que la passion est toujours
présente à Marseille mais aussi la
violence mais aussi la spéculation
effectivement et l'origine de cet argent
voyez quand des lit de chirurgie atte un
million de francs donc ça fait quelques
millions et pour rendre très rentable ce
genre de clinique d'où vient l'argent ça
c'est la question qu'on peut se poser
c'est pour-ce qu'il pourrait venir de la
drogue est-ce qu'il pourquoi pas ça ça
peut être effectivement une façon de
recycler l'argent salale comme on les
comme l' recyclé déjà dans des
opérations foncières ou immobilières
pourquoi pas aussi dans ces opérations
blanchiment de l'argent cela pourrait
toucher des hommes politiques locaux ça
touche en tant cas un certain nombre de
notabilité certainement enfin même une
victime comme le docteur Péchard on sait
qu'il avait une vie assez agitée qu'il a
fait passer de l'argent noir en Suisse 5
millions accuse la la sœur de sa
maîtresse qu'est-ce que c'est ex
d'argent est-ce que à votre avis on est
au début d'une affaire ou au bout de
l'affaire au tout début d'une affaire à
mon avis même pendant le weekend il va y
avoir un développement assez
considérable c'est qu'on va monter assez
haut probablement au S des inculpations
dans dans la direction de C clinique
autrement dit d'autres personnalités
pourraient être compromises oui et si je
comprends bien il y a à la fois le corps
médical enfin une partie de ce corps
médical qui est affecté je crois qu'il
ne faut pas incriminer tous les médecins
de Marseille ENF ce serait terrible sont
des bavures sont des bavures mais sont
des bavures qui atteignent des
professions libérales par exemple les
médecins c'est pas la première fois que
des médecins sont compromis à Marseille
il a dans temps un pédiatre qui
s'appelait bsquet qu'on a retrouvé dans
la French ccinian Connection interrogé
par le juge Michel à Palerme il y avait
les grâces médicales des baettes qui n'a
pas été résolu judiciairement mais il
paraît qu'un certain nombre de de Truant
de la drogue notamment sont sortis grâce
à des à des certificats médicaux
délivrés par des médecins et
rappelez-vous qu'il y a eu quand même
des inculpations dans ce coramp médical
il pourrait y avoir un autre livre de de
votre part sur Marseille il y aura
toujours une suite au ministère de
Marseille malheureusement j'ai
l'impression que la mauvaise réputation
lui à la peau on pourrait dire lu colle
au vieux port à Marseille mais enfin il
y a d'autres affaires dans d'autres
grandes villes il y a l'affire Bou à
Paris l'affaire Fontan à Paris oui
l'affaire Boulin pour moi c'est clair
c'est un suicide mais enfin bon c'est
pas une affaire tellement mystérieuse
mais le Non Non mais à Marseille il y a
quand même une spécificité de cette
ville qui est une une ville à part qu'on
le veille ou non pour des raisons
géographiques et historiques Marseille
c'est d'abord un port ouvert à tous les
trafics de la mer et fermé sur le sur le
continent je pe remarquer c'est comme
une île Marseille on peut y aller tout
de même en tout cas ça vous incitera
peut-être à écrire un autre liv vous y
retournez et vous y serez peut-être avec
Jean-Marie ponto avec qui vous avez
écrit ce livre enquête sur les mystères
de Marseille c'est un livre de poche
merci Jacques de rogis et bonne enquête
merci l'autre grand titre de ce 1920
c'est la tempête l'ouragan qui a dévasté
toute l'Europe de l'Ouest 63 morts dont
une dizaine en France la région la plus
touchée en France c'est le Nord pcalé où
un million d'habitants ont été privés
hier d'électricité l'enquête de nos nos
camarades de du Nord patcalé Luc
laginoucher et Pierre brac reportage
pyones é ventré ligne électrique arraché
hier le résseau EDF a souffert au plus
fort de la tempête près d'un million de
personnes se sont retrouvées sans
courant toute la nuit et toute la
journée les équipe deedf ont été sur le
pied de guerre ici on les voit mettre en
place une potence de bois pour soutenir
provisoirement les câbles pourtant tout
n'est pas encore réparé et 15 à 20000
foyers vont passer la nuit dans
l'obscurité notamment dans le le Pas de
Calais et sur le littoral mais selon les
responsables d' DF tout devrait rentrer
dans l'ordre ce weekend en effet la
réalimentation du réseau est progressive
elle dépend des difficultés rencontrées
sur le terrain pour la réparation des
dégâts à gravelg près de Dunkerque la
centrale nucléaire est à nouveau en
marche hier
EDF avait dû stopper quatre des six
réacteurs parce que les pilones
distribuant l'électricité s'était brisé
enfin les difficultés que connais EDF se
répercutent sur le réseau téléphonique
régional pour faire face les services
techniques des Télécom ont installé huit
groupes électrogènes pourtant de
nombreuses lignes sont encore coupé tout
devrait être rétabli ce weekend voilà
vous découvrez la qualité de notre
réseau régional on retrouve tout de
suite en direct à rouan Alain Lecler
Alain bonsoir d'innombrables bâtiments
publics et privés ont été touchés une
douzaine de blessés dont un grave et
plusieurs dizaines de millions de francs
de dégâts voilà pour l'essentiel
l'essentiel de l'après tempête dans la
scène maritime mais l'incident le plus
spectaculaire s'est déroulé à diep où le
ferry chartre a réussi à regagner le
port mais en heurtant la digue ce qui a
provoqué une importante voie d'eau et ce
n'est que ce soir que l'on a su qu'il
n'allait pas carrément sombrer dans le
port de diepp les images de ce sauvetage
versaill c'est le gros le chartre c'est
le petit à 9h ce matin il est très mal
15 degr de Git le ventre plein d'eau le
chartre entre en soins intensifs comme
pour beaucoup de grands malades la nuit
a failli être fatale et à l'AUE sur
lesqu croyait perdu la cargaison de
poids lourd et de camionnette pouvait
riper d'un moment à l'autre en voyant
aussitôt le navire par le fond tendu sur
ses haussières le bâtiment attendait le
coup de grâce pompiers personnel de la
cying Comex se sont mobilisés pour
donner une dernière chance au feribbot
toutes les pompes disponibles sont
rassemblées le navire avale des milliers
de mètres cubes par sa déchirure sur
babord il faut pomper pomper encore
évacuer cet afflu d'eau sauver le
chartre les plongeurs de la Comex
entrent en scène déjà le matin quand le
navire menacçait de basculer il n'avait
pas hésité à plonger sous la coque pour
évaluer les dégâts euh est-ce que dans
cette zone d'aspiration on pourrait
envoyer de l'étoupe pour faire les
tité allez je pense maintenant ils
peuvent intervenir efficacement et
simplement c'est la technique du bouchon
le chartre ferryb de 122 m de long va
être sauvé par quelques kilos de chiffon
judicieusement placés par des plongeurs
professionnels qui ne voyaient pas à 20
cm sous l'eau
le traitement réussi l'hémorragie stoppé
le malade s'est tout doucement redressé
il ne reste plus qu'un peu d'huile de
coute pour assécher les coursiv ensuite
tout doucement le convalescent ira se
reposer en cale sèche pendant quelques
semaines avant de
repartir regardons maintenant ce qui
s'est passé chez nos voisins notamment
l'Angleterre la Belgique et les Pays-Bas
avec natthalie
darigrand la Grande-Bretagne encore sous
le choc hier soir les ventes atint les
170 km/h et le bilan est lourd au moins
45 morts des dizaines de blessés la
tempête a surpris les Britanniques en
plein jour dans leur voitur dans les
rues témoins cette autoroute à la sortie
de Londres fermée sur plusieurs
kilomètres des dizaines de véhicules
sont renversés dans le sud-ouest du pays
près d'un million de foyers sont
toujours privés d'électricité le montant
des dégâts est évalué à plus de 8
milliards de
francs 21 morts au Pays-Bas là aussi ce
sont les accidents de la circulation et
les chutes qui ont été les plus mortels
l'aéroport d'Amsterdam a été fermé
quelques heures ce soir la circulation
sur les routes a pu être
rétablie spectaculaire encore seette
fermees détruit en Belgique au total et
sur l'ensemble du pays 10 personnes sont
mortes en Allemagne de l'Ouest on parle
de SEP victimes la Communauté européenne
a décidé ce soir d'accorder une aide
d'urgence au pays
sinistrés pardon pour cette litanie
morbide depuis le début du journal on ne
parle que de catastrophe et de victimes
mais un autre accident s'est produit un
accident aérien un avion s'est écrasé la
nuit dernière à une vingtaine de
kilomètres de l'aéroport John Kennedy de
New York l'avion effectué la liaison
Bogota New York le bilan est terrible 67
morts et plusieurs dizaines de blessés
Véronique
gorel un enchevêtrement de toles et de
corps au milieu des débris le cri celui
d'une enfant
rescapé de la carlingue défoncée les
sauveteurs se sont efforcés pendant les
heures de retirer les survivants
plusieurs dizaines de blessés 67 morts
au moins le bilan reste provisoire le
vol avion K52 qui effectué la liaison
Bogota New York transporté 158 passagers
il s'est écrasé à covneek à Long Island
à 25 km à peine de l'aéroport Kennedy
les causes de l'accident restent
confuses d'abord il y a les conditions
météorologiques très mauvaises moins de
800 m de visibilité en raison de la
pluie et du brouillard ensuite ce
message capté entre la tour de contrôle
et le pilote quelques minutes avant
l'accident nous n'avons plus de
carburant les réacteurs ne fonctionnent
pas donnez-nous des instructions pour
atterrir la panne de carburant une
hypothèse retenu par les enquêteurs
l'avion un Boeing 707 s'est disloqué
mais n'a pas pris feu en s'écrasant
c'est ce qui explique sans doute le
nombre élevé de survivants autre
hypothèse celle de l'attentat l'avion
avait fait Escal bendeline une hypothèse
peu probable selon les enquêteurs la
boîte noire a été récupérée son examen
devrait permettre d'en savoir
plus Le Front populaire d'Azerbaïdjan
s'apprêtait à proclamer la prise du
pouvoir c'est ce que vient d'indiquer le
ministre soviétique de la défense cela
rend le pouvoir soviétique très nerveux
y compris à Moscou où une personnalité
azérie a été arrêtée Joë Azard le siège
de la représentation d'azerbaïjan à
Moscou investi la nuit dernière par des
unités spéciales du ministère de
l'Intérieur un nouvel avertissement
soviétique à l'encontre des
nationalistes azéries une quinzaine de
policiers ont en effet perquisitionné
Manu militar à deux reprises le bâtiment
ils y ont arrêté l'un des dirigeants du
Front populaire
d'azerbaïjanektibar mahedov avait
dénoncé quelques heures auparavant au
cours d'une conférence de presse
l'intervention de l'armée à Bakou
commentaire du kremmelin mamedov était
venu dans la capitale préparer des
activités contre la société cet incident
grave ainsi que les révélations du
ministre soviétique de la défense selon
lesquels le Front populaire
d'Azerbaïdjan s'apprêtait à prendre le
pouvoir apparaît ce soir comme une
nouvelle réplique au critique des
partisans du dialogue à tout prix le
général yzov a également justifieré
l'intervention de l'armée par le nombre
de rebelles en armes en Azerbaïdjan ils
sont 40000 selon lui dans les rues de
Bakou une détente apparente mais les
arrestations se multiplient 147
personnes appréhendé la nuit dernière
Moscou manie la carotte et le bâton en
recherchant toujours par ailleurs le
dialogue avec les modérés du Front
populaire
aérie nous l'avons appris en début de
soirée anis Nakache arrête sa grève de
la fin l'intégriste iranien avait été
condamné à la réclusion à perpétuité
pour avoir tué deux Français au cours
d'une tentative d'attentat contre
Chapour bactiar Jean-François Gringoire
au 138e jour anis nakach a donc décideré
de mettre un terme à sa grffe de la fin
enfermé dans l'infirmerie de la prison
de freine nakche pèse aujourd'hui 48 kg
et ne se déplace qu'en fauteuil roulant
il somnol toute la journée mais arrive à
lire et à regarder la télévision il y a
un mois et demi les médecins l'ont mis
contre son gré sous transfusion depuis
il la supporte ce soir son état général
est faible et il a déjà par deux fois
susciter l'inquiétude de la Chancellerie
nakchee condamné à perpétuité pour
l'attentat raté contre chapau bactier en
1980 exigeait que les autorités
françaises tiennent leur promesses selon
le terroriste c'était la libération des
otages français du Liban contre la
sienne et d'après ses avocat il était
déterminé à aller jusqu'au bout alors
pourquoi anis nakakach a-t-il mis fin à
son jeûne trois hypothèses il a pu tout
simplement craquer ou bien les propos
intransigeentss tenus récemment par
François miteran sur sa situation ont
fait comprendre au prisonniers que ce
n'est pas comme ça qu'il obtiendrait sa
libération enfin il est aussi possible
que cet arrêt synonyme de message reçu
soit l'annonce d'un prochain dénouement
dans laffiren cach drôle de festival
politique à Cannes une élection
municipale partielle doit se dérouler
dimanche Michel Mouillot le maire
sortant doit repasser devant les
électeurs il est confiant il est certain
de battre ses adversaires de gauche mais
il est perturbé par le nombre de
candidats à droite et ils sont nombreux
le reportage de Philippe de seski et de
Bruno
[Musique]
carou n'est pas d'Allas mais son univers
politique est vraiment impitoyable jugez
vous-même en mars dernier les noms
d'oiseaux volent à Touva durant la
campagne le RPR demande l'annulation de
l'élection de l'UDF Michel Mouillot il
l'obtient mais se précipite ensuite dans
les bras du même Mouillot au nom de
l'Union union à peine réalisé qu'elle
est dénoncée par le RPR national qui
entend ainsi faire payer au RPR local
son soutien à passqui contre irréaliste
NZ pas de c
ma face à Michel Mouillot qui maintient
sa liste avec des RPR le goliste pierre
Dozol prend la tête de la
dissidence sur la liste de Monsieur
Mouillot les RPR qu'il a pris ne sont
pas RPR ce sont des RPR qui ont dû
prendre leur carte il y a quelques jours
regardez comme c'est g du Pin béni pour
le Front national mais là aussi la
division n'a pu être surmontée Albert
Peron investi par Le Pen se retrouve
confronté à l'ancien candidat
Jean-Bernard pin je dirais que Monsieur
pon dans cette affaire j'ai un
contentieux personnel avec lui car je
n'aime pas les parachutés les canois
n'iment pas les parachutés monsieur pin
n'est qu'une marionnette dans l'affaire
et qui est manipulé contre le Front
national devant cette cacophonie Michel
mou préfère défendre son bilan laissant
de côté les étiquettes politiques CAN et
je crois que c'est un engage que tout le
monde comprend la gauche de son côté est
affaiblie d'abord par la présence d'un
candidat écologiste Paul Vogel investi
par les ver ensite parce que gu P pour
le PC a refusé de Sallier à H Ross le
candidat
socialiste se retrouve un conseil
municipal avec une absence totale de
représentants de la
gauche prier tour incertain et pour le
second rien n'est à
exclure même si Michel mouot est favori
le candidat UDF pourrait souffrir d'une
triangulaire concurrencé par le RPR
dissident pierre Dozol et le lepéniste
Albert Peron nombreux d'électeurs
désabusés risquent d'aller à la pêche et
l'abstention a souvent profité lors de
partiel au Front
national
le beau parcours de Noah à Melbourne
s'est achevé en demi-finale il a été
battu par un homme à la drôle de
casquette lel une casquette de
légionnaire cé assez curieux mais il
paraît qu'il a un soleil terrible là-bas
à Melbourne Noah battu mais tout de même
cel reste encourageant pour lui
Caroline je me suis fait entubé voici
comment no a décrit le premier set de
son match la ballade australienne s'est
transformé en marche forcée face au
légionnaire des cours Lendel noas se
fait prendre son service d'entrée perd
le premier set 6-4 le souvenir de sa
victoire sur le tque à Sydney et bien
loin lle n'est pas numéro 1 mondial pour
rien la suite du match une longue galère
selon les termes de Noah tétanisé au
fond du cours comme écrasé par la
chaleur et l'impuissance dépassé dans
l'exercice de son arme favorite la volé
lendle prend une revanche facile 64 61
62 Noah déçu mais sa victoire de Sydney
cette demi-finale le font grimper dans
le classement ATP il est maintenant 9e
joueur
mondial nous allons nous rendre dans un
instant en direct à angoulê au théâtre
d'angoulê pour la 17e édition du
Festival de la bande dessinée d'angoulem
nous allons retrouver Christian desplace
mais avant de rejoindre Christian un
reportage tout à fait insolite comment
les nipons autrement dit les Japonais
voit-il notre BD notre bande dessinée
regardons
plus d'un million et demi de Japonais
vont regarder cette présentation du
Centre national de la bande diné le ciel
est
couvert au micro l'une des
présentatrices vett de la chaîne par
satellite NHK may que les
téléspectateurs Britanniques vont
également découvrir dans l'émission de
la BBC sur angoulem préparé par Peter
Adam
l'équipe de la NHK basée à Paris est
venue tourner angoulem son émission
bimensuelle weekend on Europe une heure
de programme consacré à angoulem et son
salon pour la seconde fois en 2
ans la plupart des Japonais connaissent
Paris ou peut-être Nice et c'est tout
pour angoulem ce sera nouveau ce serait
une aventure pour les Japonais d'essayer
de venir angoulem
non may vient de couvrir les récents
événements en Europe de l'Est côté
cultur pour elle le salon de la bande
dessinée est une autre façon de montrer
l'esprit de l'Europe à des Japonais par
ailleurs fous de BB ce n'est pas
angoulem qui s'en plaindra dont les
images font le tour du
monde et ce festival Christian que nous
rejoignons donc en direct au théâtre
d'angoulem ce festival a attiré d'autres
étrangers notamment les Anglais
exactement Paul il y a un mot
supplémentaire dans le dictionnaire des
amateurs de bande dessiné comique
c'est-à-dire BD dans la langue de
Shakespeare les dessinateurs anglais ont
débarqué en force re manche il faut dire
que les adultes commencent à lire des
albums et ça c'est vraiment nouveau
autre raison de ce débarquement expliqué
dans la patrie des charantaises les
dessinateurs francophones auraient
chaussé leur crayon de pantoufles et
manqueraiit de créativité un débat qui
n'est vraiment pas clos actuellement à
quelques mètres d'ici et vous le voyez
actuellement le monde de la bande
deessée remet ses prix cérémonie
traditionnelle des alphars le Grand Prix
cette année c'est Max caban il est avec
nous vous êtes couroné pour l'ensemble
de votre de votre uvre max caban c'est
un grand honneur est-ce que vous avez
été surpris par cette cette remise de
prix ben j'aurais du mal à dire que je
ne suis pas surpris euh car dans ces
cas-là il y a toujours une espèce de
rumeur qui rode quelques temps
auparavant qui est un peu éprouvante il
faut dire alors dans votre dernier album
qui s'appelle Colin Maillard vous parlez
d'un petit garçon qui vit dans le sud de
la France est-ce que c'est vous ce petit
garçon tout à fait bien sûr je pense que
les gens avec qui j'ai vécu mon enfance
me reconnaîtront dessus sur les dessins
euh c'est un recueil de petites
nouvelles que j'ai réalisé qui sont
entièrement autobiographiques avec C
prénom de filles différents max caban je
vous remercie beaucoup le salon de la
bande dessinée d'angoulem ici ferme ses
portes dimanche soir la capitale
charantaise Paul vous attend pour
compléter votre collection de bande
dessiné non je ne suis pas un amateur
aussi éclairé que vous mais je suggéis
volontiers aux hommes de l'art et
notamment à Max cabane de s'intéresser
de plus près peut-être à la vie
politique ça m'intéresserait ce journal
est terminé c'est le 5e journal de la
série donc de la semaine Marc hutem vous
présente a ce soir Soir 3 à 22h15 et
pendant tout le weekend vous retrouverez
désormais Éric Cachard qui présentera
tous les journaux du weekend et
notamment le 1920 de samedi et de
dimanche je crois que lui s'intéresse
particulièrement à la BD et il vous en
parlera Florence clin dans quelques
secondes ce 191 est terminé à lundi 19h
bonsoir bon
weekend
[Musique]